captain america has appeared in many
movies and tv shows but which screen
adaptations wield the shield with the
most might join us as we answer that
question by ranking every adaptation of
the original captain america from worst
to best
1944's captain america stands as the
first instance of a live-action marvel
comics adaptation undergoing a
theatrical release
it remained the only one of its kind
until 1977's spider-man
originally a made-for-tv movie played in
international theaters while the serial
warrants attention for its historic
significance it's hard to say how much
it holds up on its own merits
this version of captain america isn't a
world war ii super soldier named steve
rogers for one thing
instead he is a district attorney named
grant gardner who uses a gun instead of
his signature shield
in the first episode cap investigates a
series of mysterious deaths linked to an
ancient mayan artifact
i don't make excuses but i do have a
definite plan
this really sounds like a job more
suited for batman or any of the other
numerous costume detectives who start in
adventure serials of the era
aside from the name costume and a vague
sense that they share a power set
there's little connection between this
captain america and the character in the
comics but what the film lacks
infidelity to its source material it
makes up for in over-the-top hollywood
fight scenes
if that's your thing it's worth a gander
the mere implication that spider-man and
his amazing friends is anything less
than a groundbreaking cross-media
achievement is blasphemy against the
nerd gods so don't get it mixed up we're
not saying there's anything wrong with
amazing friends
only that the iteration of steve rogers
who appears in pawns at the kingpin is
not one of cap's more impressive turns
unlike other captains america this one's
a glory hound who spends loads of time
on athletic exhibitions to show off for
empire state university students before
one such demonstration he proudly brags
about his amazing abilities to a
cheering crowd like a carnival parker
today you will see what years of
training and exercise have done for me
not exactly humble and then he performs
speeds that would be utterly impossible
without the super soldier serum
everyone knows gave him his powers
training and exercise be
damned computer animation could be one
heck of a dice roll somehow 2014's iron
man and captain america heroes united
looks like a giant cut scene from an
outdated video game meanwhile
you could convince us 1995's toy story
came out yesterday if we didn't already
know better
something's gone wrong here but we're
not sure exactly what
instantly dated though it may be heroes
united is significant for being one of
the first contemporary instances of cap
getting brainwashed into joining hydra
this idea would prove aggressively
unpopular years later when replicated in
secret empire a 2017 marvel comics
crossover storyline then again
cap's notorious proclamation of hydra
loyalties at secret empire's onset paved
the way for one of the most gut-busting
moments in avengers endgame i always
suppose it all comes out in the wash
hail andrew ultimate avengers the movie
and ultimate avengers 2 rise of the
panther predate robert downey jr's first
on-screen outing is tony stark by
roughly two years therefore viewers of
these movies didn't necessarily
understand they were being prepared
or should we say indoctrinated to go see
a series of live-action avengers movies
that said the animated ultimate avengers
projects were clearly influenced by the
2002 comic book series the ultimate
which were totally quite different from
what the live-action mcu would come to
be the ultimates written by mark miller
reimagines earth's mightiest heroes in a
post-9 11
setting with a grim and gritty attitude
but ultimate avengers the movie is a
pretty cut and dry avengers origin story
maybe a bit too mature for the littlest
kids but a far cry from the dark
territory the ultimates comics had a
tendency to slide into with their mature
tone hardly anyone at the time
understood why these films existed or
who they were for and they were quickly
rendered superfluous by superior
avengers cartoons
is 1990s captain america really as bad
as its dismal rotten tomatoes score
makes it out to be
is it possible that audiences of the
time got their hopes up for marvel's
answer to 1989's batman and had their
spirits crushed by a mediocre straight
to vhs action romp of course this movie
isn't particularly good but it's only
terrible because it made us think marvel
superheroes wouldn't work as movies
despite all of the hokiness this version
of steve rogers still feels relatively
true to its source material this cap at
the very least gets his powers via a
super soldier program in world war
ii gets frozen and ends up having to
awkwardly adjust to modernity once he
unfreezes however it's not all true to
the comics
red skull is inexplicably italian and
cap's mask includes deeply creepy rubber
ears presumably as a means to strike
additional terror into his adversaries
we don't want to sound overly dismissive
of an avengers adaptation that isn't
targeted at an english-speaking audience
this adaptation may very well fly over
our heads only to land gracefully and
with precision for the japanese kids
it's meant for but if we understand
correctly disk wars is basically
a combination of avengers and pokemon in
which cap and his teammates are trapped
in pocket-sized plastic discs and must
be summoned when a combat situation
arises
it's not an ideal concept for cap
however who is a little too much of an
anachronism to fit into a pokemon style
world
even when the storyline continues in
marvel future avengers an anime series
that drops the shtick with the discs
cap doesn't necessarily make a case for
himself as an anime star
in 1979's made for tv movies captain
america and captain america
2 death too soon steve rogers is a
monumentally chillaxed and creative dude
who's never seen an arctic ice field in
his life his father served in world war
ii which means by the time steve was
born hitler was already too dead to
punch
late 70s steve tosses around a shield
but he also cruises in a customized red
white and blue motorcycle that converts
into a hang glider for the frequent
occasions in which he finds himself
needing a hang glider this cap's also
got a tricked-out van as well as a bulky
blue and white helmet to keep his head
safe on the road this cap strays too far
from the original for us to really
consider him an authentic captain
america but even if he's not at all a
comics accurate cap
he still seems kind of awesome the 90s
was a pretty wild time for marvel
animation
x-men kicked off in 1992 setting the
template for that era's batch of shows
spider-man fantastic four iron man the
incredible hulk and avengers united they
stand all went on to varying degrees of
success
their interconnected continuity isn't as
overt or as important as it is in the
marvel cinematic universe or even as it
typically is in the comics but
nevertheless
it's certainly the most ambitious shared
universe saturday morning cartoons could
possibly muster at the time
captain america teams up with wolverine
in a world war ii flashback and x-men's
old soldiers he also makes multiple
appearances in spider-man
most prominently during the secret wars
crossover which also includes a
fantastic four
iron man and a black cat perhaps most
importantly this captain america marks a
millennial generation's first exposure
to a solidly executed almost comics
accurate version
of the character this rendering of
marvel signature team remained on the
air from 2013 to 2019 longer than any
other avengers show and it just so
happens to coincide with the team's
all-time highest level of cultural
visibility so for ranking these captains
america
partially on their scope of influence
even a casual and infrequent avengers
assemble viewer would have to place its
cap among the mightiest of this lot
during the 90s explosion of marvel
animated projects aiming to capitalize
on x-men success
cap never got his own show that means
assemble with about half a decade on the
air contains a larger total quantity of
televised captain america than you'll
find in any other existing animated
marvel timeline but if we may pick a nit
a viewer might notice that the roger
craig smith boy's take on steve rogers
comes close to flat out mimicking chris
evans mcu performance so while we've
gotta dock this cap some points for a
lack of creativity perhaps it earns
those points back for its strength of
cross-media synergy
earth is under imminent cosmic threat
it's unlike anything we've ever faced
and skull has information on how to stop
it
today the marvel superheroes is better
understood as pop art rather than
action-centric television you've only
got to pull cap's adventures barely out
of context to recreate them as surreal
mind-expanding fever dreams but the andy
warhol-esque elements of 1966 cap
aren't the sole reason for his high
status on this list each of the show's
heroes boasts his own theme song penned
by composer jackerbot and cap's musical
call to attention is the only jingle
from that generation of marvel cartoons
many people still remember today
the lyrics trumpet when captain america
throws his mighty shield
all those who choose to oppose his
shield must yield in terms of classic
superhero songs that one's almost up
there with batman's iconic
na na nana from the 60s show and a tune
about spider-man doing whatever a spider
can
it's iconic as all get out and pairs
beautifully with this cartoon's out
there aspects
after iron man hit theaters and revealed
marvel studios intention to assemble the
avengers on screen plenty of people
weren't sure exactly how that would look
the strange and ambiguous period in
marvel licensed media resulted in the
avengers earth's mightiest heroes
which originally aired on disney xd in
the fall of 2010.
the series gives a glimpse of how the
mcu might have panned out of hank pym
and janet van dyne co-founded the
avengers
ever wanted to know what it would look
like if black widow issued avengers
membership
and stuck to professional espionage how
about a black panther joined the team in
a more official capacity and much
earlier what might have happened if the
secret scroll invasion took place before
iron man and cap left the franchise the
answers to these questions and many more
can all be found within earth's
mightiest heroes no wonder fans adore it
earth's mightiest hero's captain america
carries himself a bit more obviously
like an old man in a younger man's body
than other entries on this list he also
pushes back against iron man's
confidence in the value of futurism
and gives him grief about having no idea
what to do in a fist fight he's
multifaceted entertaining and an
essential part of the best avengers
cartoon ever made
by the time captain america the first
avenger arrived we had seen one or two
reverent
well-executed animated incarnations of
steve rogers but prior attempts to
transfer the star-spangled soldier to
live action hadn't panned out especially
well for whatever reason
creatives weren't able to quite
effectively translate a superhero with
such an optimistic disposition to a
live-action real world that could often
feel dark and dreary that all changed
with the mcu and no matter what the
future holds for captain america and
other comic book characters on screen
fans will be able to point to the first
avenger and give it credit for breaking
that cycle
in the wake of that movie's release cap
swiftly became one of the mcu's most
popular characters and a lot of that has
to do with chris evans pitch perfect
performance
in his take on the role chris evans
emphasized the kid from brooklyn aspect
of cap over his super soldier side his
temporal
displacement is often played up for
corny humor rather than as an ever
present source of angst or resentment
which also means that when his man out
of time nature is taken seriously it
hits all the harder
has it been so long
so long well i couldn't leave my best
girl
moreover despite being a century-old
scientifically enhanced superhuman
cap adds a much needed sense of
down-to-earth relatability to an
ensemble of billionaires gods robots and
monsters it's hard to imagine that there
will ever be a live-action version of
captain america that ever knows better
than this one
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
captain america and his amazing friends
are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one